mars harbors lots of mysteries and stark
contrasts endless barren stretches of
rocky wasteland lie next to tremendously
high volcanoes and the planet's surface
in general bears witness to countless
collisions in the distant past with
gigantic canyons and craters as their
solid reminder a rarefied atmosphere is
saturated with minuscule particles of
rusty sand with strong winds swirling it
in continuous furious sandstorms
this is what mars is like a mysterious
and forbidding planet let's take a
closer look at it
[Music]
mars lies approximately one and a half
times as far from the sun as the earth
in contrast to our planet its radius is
twice as small its mass is around 10.7
percent that of the earth and the
free-fall acceleration on the surface is
almost three times as little the
temperature fluctuates between
153 degrees celsius below zero at the
poles and 35 degrees celsius above zero
at the equator
the area of mars's surface is roughly
the same as that of all our continents
combined
its terrain is extremely diverse with
some geological features reminiscent of
those of our planet and others quite
unique and peculiar
the surface of mars is currently closely
observed from the planet's orbit by
eight automatic space probes the data
collected by them reveals that there is
a vast light spot in the planet's
western hemisphere this region is the
largest volcano in the solar system and
it is known as olympus mans
today this is the starting point of our
tour around the red planet
olympus mons towers as high as 26
kilometers over the plains surrounding
it
this is roughly two and a half times the
height of mount everest
it is assumed to be a shield volcano
formed with multiple sheets of
solidified lava
according to today's assumptions about
the planet's inner makeup there are no
tectonic plates under the surface
which is why magma's eruption point can
remain in the same spot for a long time
for hundreds of millions and even
billions of years
that accounts for the fact why ejected
larva spills out to cover incredibly
vast areas with a layer that
subsequently turns into a rocky shield
the average diameter of olympus mons
measures around 600 kilometers and its
area is over 300 000 square kilometers
these figures are comparable with the
area of an average sized european
country like poland or italy
a giant depression formed with six cow
dairies or collapsed volcanic craters is
located in the center of the volcano the
diameter of the depression measures
around 85 kilometers and its depth
reaches as far down as three kilometers
olympus mons is so high that the
atmospheric pressure at the top is 50
times lower than at the foot
since the atmosphere on mars is about
160 times more rarefied than that of the
earth the conditions on top of the
volcano are slightly short of those in
the vacuum
that is why the red planet's highest
mountain cannot expect any visitor
probes
the atmospheric density would be too low
for parachutes to slow down a descending
capsule with a mars rover inside
with the average slope of olympus mons
quite small at only five percent the
volcano's edges end in almost sheer
abysses of up to seven kilometers high
it still hasn't been established for
certain how such enormous slopes came to
form according to some assumptions it
was done by an ancient ocean on mars
other hypotheses held sandstorms
accountable which continuously rage in
this area
when we climb down from olympus mons and
fly over its surroundings we can see
that there are lots of overlapping
ridges and isolated mountains
some of these formations stretch as far
as a thousand kilometers from the
volcano's edge it is assumed that they
may have formed as the giant mountain
slopes were eroding or else due to
movements of ancient ice caps
whizzing on south east from olympus mons
we will find ourselves in a vast region
known as tharsis
this volcanic upland formed by
solidified streams of lava covers
roughly one-fourth of the entire
planet's surface its area of around 30
million square kilometers is comparable
with that of africa
interestingly the upland is 10
kilometers higher than the plains
surrounding it and its age could be
about 3.7 billion years
there are a great number of volcanoes
here some of which only slightly smaller
than olympus mons
aseamons for example rises as high up as
19 kilometers which makes it the second
highest peak on mars with a summit
caldera measuring 110 kilometers the
overall diameter of the mountain is over
400 kilometers
a unique natural phenomenon can be
observed over the volcano every year for
a short time as sun rays warm the
mountain slopes small dust spirals into
a dense cloud helped along by air
streams going upward
this cloud may float up to 30 kilometers
above our sea bonds and may be scattered
by winds across vast areas
vertical pits can be seen in different
places all over the upland they're quite
deep with the bottoms quite unobservable
the diameter of the largest one measures
around 150 meters and its depth cannot
be less than 178 meters
these pits are thought to be collapsed
lava tubes
tharsis is made up of dozens of
overlapping shield volcanoes
in the billions of years of their
eruptions great amounts of co2 and water
vapor were released into the martian
atmosphere
mathematical modelling shows that the
amount would be enough to shroud the
planet with an atmosphere one and a half
times as dense as that of the earth
these estimates are in direct evidence
of the fact that in the past conditions
on mars may have been more favorable for
life to originate there than now
with its gravity comparatively weak
however the planet failed to retain its
atmosphere and was eventually stripped
of it
moving on to the east from the plateau
we will get to the region known as
valles marineris
it is a network of gargantuan canyons
stretching for up to
500 kilometers
the width of the canyon reaches 600
kilometers and it's more than 11
kilometers deep
images reveal that the slopes of most of
the canyons in the central and western
parts of valles marineris have a
stratified structure typical of deposits
at the bottom of a large body of water
it is quite likely that the canyons used
to be completely submerged underwater in
the distant past
there are some truly invaluable
paleontological finds to be extracted
from the rock deposits in this region
the eastern part of the valleys are
areas with a rather chaotic relief
there are vast labyrinths made up of
comparatively small canyons abysses
mountains and plateaus
further north the terrain evens out into
a relatively smooth plain known as chris
planitia
its vast areas became the final resting
place for the debris of the sojourner
mars river and also for the viking one
probe which sent the first color images
of martian landscapes to the earth as
far back as in 1976.
according to the widely accepted
hypothesis today vallis marineris came
to be in the early stages of the
planet's formation erosion and
geological processes were to deepen and
widen the canyons later on one version
has it that the systems of casmatas is
thought to have formed after volcanic
eruptions on the tharsis upland
another version claims utopia planitia
to be the cause for their formation
which lies on the other side of the
planet
this vast round lowland is likely to be
an impact crater from an extremely large
asteroid that would have hit the
planet's surface
the planicia's diameter measures some
3300 kilometers the terrain of the
surface itself is rather flat and smooth
there were several attempts to explore
utopia planitia by different space
probes
in 1979 the viking 2 lander beamed back
panoramic images of its surface to the
earth in 2016 the charade radar on the
mro probe located rich deposits of water
ice mixed with dust underground
in may 2021 the chinese rover jurong
touched down on utopia planitia it has
covered over 1 000 metres of the red
planet's surface by now and has beamed
back hundreds of images unfortunately it
cannot dig as far down as the water
carrying layer with the latter as deep
as 1 to 10 meters down
in the north utopia planitia borders on
vestitus borealis a giant lowland
surrounding the northern part of the
planet and covering about 40 percent of
its total area
moving south west from the center of
utopia planitia we will reach
icidisplanitia
the region on its western edge has been
the focus of people's special attention
for almost eight months now
of course it is all about the jezreel
crater it is likely that millions of
years ago there used to be a body of
water here that has dried up by now
the perseverance mars rover and
ingenuity the first ever helicopter
flown beyond the earth have been
exploring the bottom of the crater since
the 18th of february 2021.
the jezreel crater was chosen from the
mission because it appeared one of the
most promising places to discover traces
of martian life
the crater is posited to have formed
around 4 billion years ago after a
massive celestial body fell on mars
the impact crater measured some 49
kilometers
as i've already mentioned it is thought
that it used to be filled with water and
the hesperian of the geological history
of mars is singled out as the most
likely period for that
the hesperians started some three and a
half billion years ago and continued for
around a billion years atmospheric
pressure on the planet at the time is
estimated to have been comparable with
that on the earth with the surface
temperature reaching 50 degrees celsius
rock samples recently extracted from the
crater's bottom by the perseverance
rover are hard evidence of that
they still have to be transported to the
earth for deeper analysis but it is
clear even now that at some point the
rocks have continuously been in close
contact with liquid water
perseverance has already delighted
scientists with great amounts of useful
data and the mission is still far from
being completed
the probe is designed for 14 years of
operation which means that there are
still hundreds of fines to extract and
kilometers of martian terrain to cover
that is why our tour around martian
expanses is not yet over
with all the considerable effort put
into studying it the red planet still
harbors innumerable mysteries
some bold predictions may come true even
in the nearest years and humans will
finally set foot on the martian surface
for the first time ever
this event will be a new major milestone
in the exploration of the solar system
and the beginning of a new era of
discoveries and as they happen we will
do our best to bring you updates on all
of them
your support means a lot to us
let's keep in touch
[Music]
you